i'm mostly including this
for the final the hashtag i recently saw
a facebook meme that people who wear
glasses are smarter because they trade
graphics for processing power
thoughts also just lane maxwell didn't
kill herself
the way you phrase that issue will not
have killed herself
that's right that's right but you know i
i she
definitely will not have i would so i
saw eric tweet about this and i
was very much glasses no oh just saying
maxwell yeah yeah
um prepare yourself that
what you expect to happen is not going
to happen yeah something else will
happen yeah it would be
it would be too obvious if it was it was
that again yeah
uh so anyway um the question about
glasses yeah they're
well first of all there is a uh a set of
trade-offs
involved in frankly reading and what it
does to your eyes
um as you will soon discover about your
teeth your teeth are suffering
from modernity your eyes are also
suffering from modernity and in fact all
of you is suffering from modernity even
as they are all profiting from modernity
as well
you know who's benefiting from identity
um
that's right um but anyway yeah there is
a certain trade-off
uh how did you specify it it was um
trade graphics for processing power
that's right that's not gonna that's
that's not gonna be it i think i think
that
often people who wear glasses do wear
glasses
because they did read a lot as children
and therefore they may
have more information in their heads
that's from books that's about as far as
you can
i like it i think that fits the
trade-off that you uh you optimize for
taking in the information uh in a very
direct fashion at some cost to your
ability to see what the hell is going on
in the world at a direct level
it seems to me it is the trade-off being
specified
i don't mean that i'm not being snide
i'm saying that just kind of what it is
i don't i don't i don't even know i'm
not sure how you
how you get there well because i mean
what it is is allowing allowing people
who have
uh you know there are many other reasons
to to end up with glasses but allowing
people uh
who have had their focus be too close at
a critical developmental period
to also see far away means that
um it would it would be a it would
appear to be trying to do an end run
around the this or that trade-off it is
um reducing the cost
side of the trade-off um by restoring
vision with
an obvious clue now the interesting
thing is you walk down the street and
you see people with glasses and you
don't think twice about the fact that
they're wearing glasses
the oddity of people wearing these
pieces of perfectly transparent glass
and plastic
shaped in a laboratory to correct for
the distortions of their own eye
is really funny i mean imagine that
instead of being in a frame which we've
gotten so used to
somehow they were hovering this far away
from your face in order that wherever
you look the photons were corrected
before they hit your retina
so well i gotta say i mean so you
alluded to
uh a podcast that you're gonna drop soon
uh
um about orthodontia which sounds like
it could not be less interesting but it
really it really would have a hard time
being more interesting
actually um i would love i don't know
who the uh relevant person over in
i land would be to the guy that you
talked to about dentistry and
orthodontia
but i would love to have that
conversation and if we don't if there is
no such person i would love to have that
conversation with you because i know
that um
you know just again anecdotally i
started
to lose my ability to see clearly far
away when i was 13 or so and it quickly
went completely off the rails you know i
was at like 2 800
with by the time i was 15. um but i
never work glasses i work contacts
and um having the experience twice a day
of like i'm gonna put in my eyes
like i'm actually gonna put in my eyes
now and now i can see and i take them
off like i can't like i know you're a
person but i can't actually tell who you
are
um and you know i'm wearing glasses on
the live stream because i started and
now it just seems like the thing to do
but
you know not wearing glasses most of the
time in my sort of real life
wearing contacts instead um it strikes
me as
not at all weird to walk around and see
people with this because it is
absolutely a hundred percent
a necessity um to move around a visual
world you are of course
solving an internet mystery of how i
ended up with you and the answer
is your vision is not what it might be
um that's ridiculous here's the thing
look internet
her glasses are excellent so yeah it may
be that without them she can't see but
she wears those things she can see
i'm corrected i'm not the expert i'm
corrected to better than 2020 with these
2015. i can see all of your flies and
here we are
that was not as comforting as it might
have been oh here we are and here we are
[Music]
yeah
you